hello everyone it is your roast coming
queen here to deliver a little pre-ep
message that
i personally consider to be um
a rite of passage of any podcast
produced in the
quarantine era which is that this
episode has some audio
issues okay our guest
her mic it makes a little crinkly sound
sometimes and um personally that's not
something that bothers me but i know
that some people
you know the way you handle
aural input is very personal to every
single person
so i wanted to give this sort of asmr
note if the idea of
hearing someone occasionally have a
crinkly microphone sound
is painful stressful to you i don't want
this podcast to be
the place for you to feel pain or or
stress
you know so so just take i want you to
know what you're taking on
before you get into the app and what
you're taking on
is an occasional crinkling
sound personally i think it's worth it
to hear the hilarious
hilarious stories of our wonderful guest
but again
that's a personal decision for you bb so
okay without further ado let's get into
the episode because i'm
i already i've run out of things to say
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who fully punched a hole in
the wall of her high school bedroom when
her mom said she couldn't go on vacation
with her boyfriend elise morales and
with us today we have an actress and
comedian who you've seen
in the cut vulture on comedy central and
most recently
crushing it in her tonight show debut
but before
all of that she was a graduate of west
hill high school it's mary beth barone
hi that was a great intro it really just
rolled off the tone
thank you i've been um i've been working
on it i come up with a new little fact
about myself at the beginning
um and then yeah you know i feel like
the intro is an important
an important intro to the place oh yeah
i mean it's just how you hook them
but it is um it sounds like your mom i
mean ultimately
yes it's upsetting to not be able to go
on vacation with your boyfriend but
also i guess kind of makes sense in a
way i went on the vacation mary beth
oh okay
let's hear about that violence works and
i did ultimately go on the vacation
with my boyfriend um who
uh he's like grandma got mad at us
because she thought we were being too
touchy feely on the vacation
and i was like well then why did you let
me even come here
wait where where'd you go florida
of course a classic place to go on
vacation with a high school vacation
spot i would say
100 did your family have like a
particular vacation spot that you guys
would go to
we really there was a wide spectrum
like some summers we would just like go
to italy for two weeks
but then sometimes we would go to
disneyland like if there was such a
range and or we'd go to like savannah
georgia to visit my aunt
you know so it was just you never knew
what my mom was going to plan
it is really like when you're when
you're a kid it's just like you find out
we're go sorry we're going on vacation
for a month actually
right so sorry if you had friends or you
had anything
that you were doing they're just like
yeah we're we're packing up the entire
family and we're leaving our house empty
for
x number of days and that's the
situation so
and it's all like it there are always
vacations that now i'm like
please someone pay for me to go i can't
even
tell you for two weeks i cannot like
i remember being miserable on a family
vacation to florida where we were like
on
my uncle has a boat we were like on his
boat i was
miserable because i could not
see this boy david who's i've talked
about him on the podcast before but his
screen name was dj school ditcher
and he was my big middle school crush
and i had like the
i had the alarm to know when he signed
on and stuff
of course yeah and i wanted to spend
time with him on spring break and
instead i had to be on my uncle's stupid
boat
i know it all felt so unfair i remember
going to italy
one year and we were like in the
mountains and it was summer and i was
like why don't they have air
conditioning here
like we were staying like in a chateau
where there were like literal oil
painting murals on the wall and i was
like
there's mosquitoes and the pool's really
cold and
it's just like the pool is cold i need
to shut up right now
all right so let's get let's get deeper
into it so this is the first question i
like to ask which is just um
tell let me know like what was the
flavor of your high school what type of
high school are we dealing with
what is the vibe okay so it's a public
school
and i was little catholic school girl
coming from greenwich catholic where
there was like 40 kids in a grade maybe
50.
there were 600 kids in my grade in high
school
and that's a great yeah that's
so was your like school was it like a
giant building like what's the campus
it's like a campus it was i think it was
three buildings and the
agricultural science program had a
separate building so any kids that were
doing that were
were separate oh wow so would they have
like
because like university of delaware aka
my college had an ag
building and they i know it's so random
yeah we i don't think we had like
livestock per se i was like how
big is this ag building no the the
school was just so
massive and so you would really just get
to know people based on what classes you
were in
because then you just spent like all day
with those people and it was like
lunchtime
so they would do lunch in three blocks
and it was
pandemonium two separate two cafeterias
fully two cafeterias
i remember like we had lunch in four
blocks at my school
and if you got a block your lunch was at
30 a.m yeah to school
the idea of getting to school at 7 25
a.m for the first spell
it absolutely blows because i can hardly
wake up at 9 00 a.m at this point
this is high school i'm doing my hair
every day i'm
picking out an outfit i never wore the
same outfit twice in high school that
was the type of person that i was i wear
the same pieces but i wouldn't wear the
same outfits
and i was very focused on physical
appearance obviously very
materialistic teenager but the idea of
getting up that early and
putting like being functioning and then
yeah lunch at 10
30 like what who is that for then you
have so much time left in your day
i would first of all i would get up at
six o'clock in the morning and be like
i'm late
i shouldn't i'm already late
like the bus is here in 15 minutes yeah
exactly
it's crazy i would somehow straighten
my hair during that time
full beat full face of makeup i would do
a smokey eye
sometimes like this was very serious
business was getting ready for high
school
it it was so la here's did you plan
out your first like week of outfits
like for first day of school because i
would always plan at least the first
week
yeah i mean i was coming from catholic
school where we had to wear uniforms so
i was just so excited to be wearing my
own clothes that i was like okay i need
to have this picked out and obviously at
that time
marissa cooper was my style icon so it
was a lot of like
wearing like a scarf as a headband a low
side ponytail a lot of denim skirts and
things like that
and a lot of necklaces um so i was i was
very focused i mean that was my main
priority in high school it
certainly wasn't my grades i mean i
would like i got fine grades and i got
into like a
good college because i applied to like
the easiest school to get into within
that college but
i was and i were you know i did my
homework and [ __ ] but i was like
not like i wasn't like a nerd yeah
so where did teen mary beth like funnel
her
self into socially i always ask this of
people who went to a big high school
like how do you make a splash
in a class of 600. and you did you make
a splash
yeah it was really i think it was just
really like
natural i fell into this group that had
mostly all gone to middle school
together
and um i was lucky enough to be in a lot
of overlapping classes with them
and they were very social on the
weekends like we would always go hang
out at someone's house
so it was really nice to be able to have
that like
when i was obviously really intimidated
going to a new school
and i was also on the swim team where
you make you know you make friends that
was a
fall sport so that was right when i was
a freshman going in
going to swim practice but i i and i
made a lot of friends on the team but
they weren't
the type of friends that i would
necessarily like
hang out with on a friday night those
were my like friends from the classes
and i remember solidifying my friendship
with them because i kind of like
asked what they were doing for new
year's so this is like january just a
few months in
and i went to their new year's party so
that what felt very good
that is that is a huge like way to
assert yourself in a group
it's to be like you're ringing in the
new year with me and i'm coming to your
house you know what was a
i feel like you'll relate to this there
was a huge moment where new year's eve
shifted as a holiday for me where i
understood it to be the very like sexy
fashion holiday it is
is the oc new year's eve episode
where ryan tells marissa that he loves
her and she's going to the party at
oliver trash
house so you should know
um i watched the oc season one recently
and i just watched season one and then i
watched the series finale because
i wanted to just watch when it was like
at its best
but that season one is perfect there's
like it's
it's so good and like it really wasn't
that like inappropriate i mean i
like gossip girl i think was way worse
for like sex stuff
yeah doesn't chuck chuck's like fully
attempts rape in the pilot yeah so
that's not great it's not great and i
think like
those there i i watch back the oc season
one and i didn't realize how many
of julie cooper's lines are just
constantly on a loop in my head
like you know how there's just move
lines from movies and tv shows you just
think about sometimes
yes they're almost all from her from
season one of the oc
she's so perfect in that show julie
cooper nickel
this just like cares about her kids
that's all i mean she definitely slept
with luke which was not acceptable
that wasn't right and i made a tick tock
about this because season one
i had whiplash from think seeing is luke
a good guy or a bad guy because like
he'll be a bad guy and then he'll
randomly loki be good and then he'll be
bad again and then he'll be good
and then he like punches ryan and burns
down the house and then he's good again
and it's just and then he like moves
away with his gay dad
yeah well it's also it is kind of weird
that they're like ultimately
at the end of the day luke's dad is gay
yeah and and we have that's called
character development
it's like it's kind of like all of his
sins get wiped away
because his dad is gay and it's like
and now he has to take that on and now
he's moving
so yeah it's like what well he has to
leave orange county
if he's gonna but he does support his
dad which i think is
nice and so that show was very formative
actually in high school my friends and i
made a parody of the oc called the fc
about fairfield county and we had a huge
following in canada on the canadian oc
message boards but
i think the videos got taken down
because we used some of the songs from
the actual soundtrack
and you know copyright copyright on
youtube has changed in the last like 10
years but back then
they were not no no no yeah you could
post whatever
i remember i would make like parody
videos and stuff
with my friends we made one about the
breakfast club called the mid-morning
snack club
love it so parody was very strong
uh very very strong at that time this
was when youtube was so
new and it was you could you just
thought like okay well all of our dreams
can come true here
like this is a place where we can upload
the videos we made that are
gonna that are funny to us so they're
definitely gonna be funny to everyone
i like our drama class we would do
a video project every year and i don't
even think i did upload them to youtube
but i would work i would like learn to
edit and work
so hard on these videos in like i'm
movie
and now if i have to like edit one
second of an audition i'm like
oh my god i can't be happier i don't
have these skills i don't know how to
put captions on a video and like when i
was a teenager i would just be like i
will learn
and you would just google it yeah no we
did so many video projects in school i
was never the one editing them but if
you had to do a project and video was an
option i feel like
you would i would just pair with someone
that knew how to do it and then
had a camera so were you like
did you want to be in front of the
camera did you do
plays like what was your relationship to
comedy or performance at all during this
time
i definitely went into high school with
the intention of like auditioning for
the school play and like
doing that whole deal but i never did i
just simply never did
i think i played tennis in the spring at
least for a couple years and that was
when the plays were
so yeah i just didn't like i didn't feel
that drawn to
the drama program there um but i
always like i think my high school
friends really helped me develop
like my obviously my family was very
influential with my comedy as well but
my high school friends were like they
didn't miss a beat like we all found the
same things funny
and we would do a lot of just like
goofing off you know what i'm just like
yeah like well it seems like you guys
made this sketch series together so it's
like
like it it seems like you guys were
creative
in other ways even if you weren't
officially a part of the theater program
right we made it we made you know the
world's a stage as they say so
we made the world our little stage and i
think i was always the one that wanted
to be like
you know the main character or in front
of the camera
so in the fc were you the marissa
marissa cooper
okay okay i figured you were marissa but
hey there's a summer in there i could
see you pulling a summer
i think at the time you know one of my
friends
played she just she just knew she just
nailed the role
and i was more of a marissa anyway so i
figured you know what let's just let's
go with let's just stay true to who i am
perfect well okay let's see
so you're doing your student athlete
you've
got this crew of friends how about
like boys dating are we dating girls at
all what's going on there
boy so i was like boy crazy from the
jump
i have always been like having like i
just had crushes on people my entire
life
freshman year i had a crush on so
freshman year i like
sort of dated i mean we were like on you
know boyfriend and girlfriend but we
never really
did anything um with my friend who's now
my gay best friend
so beautiful it was very influential and
you know
we had a lot of fun it lasted i think
like maybe two months
but that year was mostly occupied by
like later that year i mean i had a
crush on a junior when i was a freshman
and who was also a swimmer that never
went away um
and did he did he reciprocate at all or
was it a fully unrequited
scenario we would talk on instant
messenger sometimes and then
see when he was a senior and i was a
sophomore
or maybe yeah we were both at the same
sweet 16 and we ended up making out
which was huge
oh it was like a dream come true yeah
that's that's like um
like disney movie level yeah but that
was the
that was it that was that was the end of
that so
i had a crush on someone from my
confirmation class actually
so classic place to develop a crush yeah
so confirmation class was this funny
dynamic because it was all these boys
from the all-boys school
and then anyone else you know from the
neighborhood who was gonna get confirmed
which is a sacrament that
not a lot of people do but i did and
so it was like funny because you would
talk to the boys on instant messenger
all week and then when you got to
confirmation class they would completely
ignore you
like they wouldn't acknowledge you of
course
so that was record um and so are the
boys from confirmation class also like
they're not necessarily boys from your
school oh they were not they were from
the all boys school
okay so that is like nothing was more
like sexually enticing to me as a
teenager than the prospect of meeting
boys from another school
it really felt like anything could
happen that is ultimately so
by senior year i was friends with a girl
in my neighborhood who went to a private
school that was co-ed
and i ended up dating my first like real
boyfriend
was one of her friends so that was
obviously very exciting
but this crush in confirmation class
like we would talk
so much on aim and like we would maybe
write on each other's facebook wall here
and there
but then um it ended really weirdly like
he was really making me feel unsafe
that sucks yeah yeah and it's
i don't know i i also feel like when
you're a
teenage girl especially it's hard to
even like
recognize when someone's making you feel
unsafe too because there's so much
um alarming behavior that is portrayed
as uh love and
and the way that you're supposed to act
like well it was weird because one
so we all had driver's licenses at this
point so this must have been
this must have been sophomore year or
junior year but
um he like he went to a different school
and
my school had a half day or his school
had a half day
and he came around to my school like
when we were getting out of class
and like was just like it was just
really bizarre and then there would be
times where i felt like
because he lived in my neighborhood and
i felt kind of like he was following me
around maybe
so eventually i had to facebook message
my brother's college roommate because my
brother was abroad
and i just was like i don't know what to
do about this guy and
i need your help and did he did he hook
it up told me exactly what to say
and event yeah then that kind of was the
end of that oh that's a good
brother's college roommate i know i know
he's
he's like he is he's a good person and i
was glad he was there for me in that
trying time yes so is
um le is team mary beth you know you
said you made
out but you also it seems like you're
very uh
you're very catholic at this point so
are you going beyond making out at all
and let's also actually pull up but we
do have a catholic image of mary beth
and i think now is the time
and this is at my confirmation all my
friends came it was like a huge
huge um day for me a huge evening to
renounce satan
you know as a teenager i wanted to wear
a cute little outfit from urban
outfitters
and i had my girls roll up and so
i was of the mind at this point that i
was waiting until marriage to have sex
so
you could definitely do other stuff but
that was like a scene that wasn't until
i was a senior like up until i was a
senior i was doing
kissing and that's it so i do want to
say also
this image that we're looking at i would
say is like
um sort of a who's who of confirmation
fashion absolutely we have all the
different because i was never confirmed
but i
you know i rolled up for my girls who
were getting confirmed my catholic ride
for your girls
yeah for my catholic girlies i showed up
to a couple confirmations and this
the um the floral v-neck dress with like
the
belt or like yeah that's a forever 21
exclusive
we that dress made the rounds because i
wore that to a sweet 16
and then my other friend also worked we
all wore that dress
once that that dress in general and that
cut of dress with like the v-neck and
then it's
like empire waisted at the bottom yeah i
feel like that was the go-to
like i have a slightly fancy maybe
professional
high school event that i need to oh yes
i mean
the way we swap dresses for sweet 16s as
if anybody gave a [ __ ]
like what we were wearing or if anyone
wore the same it was just like
we constantly like i remember i went to
one sweet 16
and i borrowed someone else's prom dress
like i was like because i just wanted to
wear something
different yeah was it like a gown did
you wear it it was short it was a
strawberry
jacob's dress and i was obsessed with it
and i was like i thought like
this you know i just you just feel like
when you dress up for those events you
feel like a million bucks
yeah because i so i was imagining you
showing up in a gown to someone else's
sweet 16 and i was like oh i did do that
well it wasn't a gown it was short but
you know it was it was someone else's
yeah were did you have a sweet 16 was
that like a big
thing in your because i feel like a
party i didn't do
the evening like renting out a venue but
a lot with a dj but a lot of people did
and those were [ __ ] fun
yeah i feel like i didn't live in like a
sweet 16 area
like either everyone's doing that or
they're not
doing it we were we were a hotbed for
sweet 16.
because there's a venue here that's not
super dressy but it's like
perfect for that like occasion and i
feel like they just would
just churn out sweet 16s so what about
for the dances were you
like going were you always going with
like a romantic partner did you go with
friends
for homecoming we you didn't usually
necessarily bring a date so those were
just like chill ones with friends but
for prom
so you had prom as a junior and a senior
junior year i just brought a friend
who like i had a crush on but we had
made out once and i was just like i
didn't get vibes from him necessarily
that
we would make out again which we have
since of course and now we're very good
friends
um that's beautiful senior year i
brought my boyfriend and i went to his
prom as well
and so was he uh so he was a different
school
ah the sexiest thing it was
it was magic really it was great he was
a great boyfriend
um and i ran into him on metro north
before the pandemic
lovely guy well i did see in your fallon
set
that you're dating someone in the uk now
which is kind of like dating someone
from another school
once again as an adult yeah yeah that's
the way you date someone from another
school as an adult
you just have to find a different
country yeah they have to live in a
completely different country
um do you remember
any like big scandals rumors
dramas of your high school
or even middle school because i love a
catholic school drama
catholic school i can't the school was
so small like
if anything it would be parental drama
which like i don't want to blow up
anyone's spot
but yeah we had a few of cases of that
in high school
one of our teachers got fired for
smoking weed with the students cool um
and i didn't endure dating one of the
students i can't remember which one it
was or maybe it was both
i feel like once you're smoking weed
with the students you're
one step away from getting one of these
yeah
we also had my favorite english teacher
married my favorite
history teacher and they were like a
very cute little couple
and they had a kid they have i think a
couple kids at this point but
it was just like it was beautiful to see
that type of
you know workplace that's a positive
that's that's a positive
romance education well just two adults
yeah just two adults falling in love
kind of at work
different departments but we love to see
it there was
definitely rumors of like stds and stuff
like you would hear about so-and-so
having
whatever but um and then i'm trying to
one one year there was everybody was
convinced that there was going to be a
shootout at the school between students
and so i stayed home that day so
was the shootout was it one of those
things where it's like tomorrow
lunch these two people are gonna shoot
each other i don't even know if it was
specific people or specific like cliques
or what it was but
we also had several bomb threats at my
school
wow so was it always like did you ever
find out who did them was it like
disgruntled students who did them
i think that bomb threats were students
i don't know who spread the rumor about
the shootout but that was
definitely like peak high school drama i
was like oh my god
who's gonna stay home tomorrow and who's
not um
so that's the people who didn't it's
like those
those people are like yolo i guess these
are like
or or they don't feed into the drama
that's true
they either didn't believe it or they
were like
i'm trying to see a shootout at my
school okay if it's happening i'm gonna
be there in the audience exactly
exactly there was one more thing that i
thought of
but i can't remember so if i if i think
of it
i will let you know i remember i went to
like a weird christian
elementary school like up until sixth
grade and after
columbine someone wrote
we had like um handball
courts out that were like outside where
you like hit the ball against the thing
and someone local teens
came onto the playground and they wrote
marybeth they wrote god is gay
on the playground and everyone was
really scared
that it was going to lead to everybody
was free
oh my god i remembered what i was going
to say senior year
okay i took latin in high school because
i didn't want to have to learn how to
speak another language which is so
stupid because
how beneficial is it to keep multiple
languages um
and they're literally teaching you for
free but i said yeah i'm gonna take
latin
so there's this thing called connecticut
state latin day which is where latin
students from every school could come
and you would wear togas and you would
do like traditional things that they
would do
in like ancient greece or whatever and
so
i remember i knew a few of the boys from
the all-boys school
who were in latin and so i got really
stoned with some of my friends before we
went on the bus
to connecticut's day latin day and i was
so high
like i was in a toga and like just
trying to like
casually flirt with people and it was it
was a great i mean hey it was a great
day
but um and that sounds honestly
wonderful
like a beautiful day um what was teens
teen mary beth's like move with guys
would it be
to would it be the i am would it be
the sarcastic like i actually hate you
i never approach things with i don't
think i really ever approach
things as like nagging or saying like
trying to like reverse
psychology type deal it was mostly just
like
um pretty blatant flirting i would say
yeah you know what
there's a lot to be said for that
because people know what you're doing
they know exactly there's not a lot of
confusion that's there
if you're just laying it all out i think
i was a mixture of blatant flirting and
also
unfortunately like guys girling
yeah i get that i mean well
also there's nothing wrong with that
like if you're being i mean sometimes
it's fun to hang out with guys
i guess right like if you're being true
to yourself then i think there's nothing
wrong with that
i do think that i was being true to
myself but i also
think that i was um
like putting more pressure on my female
friendships than
and expecting nothing from my male
friendships and so that leads to
conflict when it's like you don't
literally don't expect them to do
anything but your girlfriends it's like
she looked at me the wrong way and it
means something right
and those are that's some social
politics that it's good to learn in high
school because then you can navigate
those things into adulthood because they
still happen that's true were you a high
drama
friend group like did you guys fight
with each other or
was it very like because our group was
it was i think i think it was nine girls
and two guys who both are gay
now that came out in high school um so
it was like
people would maybe get mad at each other
about things but it was usually like oh
this person told something to someone
that they weren't supposed to
or like never like we never really
really wanted to hook up with the same
people
that really kind of removed all any well
there i guess there were a couple
instances of that but on the whole
it was pretty drama free and you can't
make it through high school without a
couple instances of that yeah
to be like oh my god this guy actually
likes my friend
it happens it definitely happens it
happens to the best of us
even beautiful people oh absolutely it
you know that really
it just tran like it doesn't
discriminate no it could happen to
anyone
and we were kind of like i liked my
group of friends was fun because we kind
of struck the balance between being like
breaking the rules and also just like
doing our homework like
we definitely like we're good at school
but we
like we weren't supposed to leave campus
at lunch even if we had cars
um because we couldn't leave when i hear
about people who could leave i'm like
no we were trapped in our school the
moment you arrived you were supposed to
try
to be trapped i would leave every single
day when i had a car
and we would go to to lizzie bagels
on high ridge road and we would get the
massive a massive slice of pizza that
cost two dollars
and just eat there and then race back to
class
i was so i tried sneaking out i tried
leaving one
time um and i was caught
leaving and they made me come back and
it was really sad
it was yeah oh you know what wait
actually there was drama because our
principal slept with one of the janitors
okay but how did everybody say she was
married i don't know but i think she was
married i'm not sure
it you know how things just kind of like
snowball in your head and you're like
what actually happened i don't know but
um
she that was drama that is drama
that's high drama we never i never knew
anything about what my principal was up
to we never had
rumors really about teachers or anyone
there was like one teacher who was
creepy but it wasn't even a rumor it was
just something that me and my friends
knew
i think something that's something
that's important for the listeners to
know is that i had a hot guidance
counselor
that is extremely important how did you
navigate that
as a young and impressionable team girl
you know i think that's where i really
learned to open up to hot guys because
he was hot and i was going to him for
stuff so
i knew he helped me get into college i i
think he did he wrote a really
he let me read his letter of
recommendation which you're literally
not supposed to do
um but he did let me read it
and it was really good and on graduation
day i remember i took a photo with him
and
you know it was cute he was very nice to
me
did you have like a for real crush on
him or were you just like
i understand this man to be hot i also
realize our relationship is professional
it was more the latter i would say yeah
what about were you and
big unrequited crushed person or did you
mostly were you like
either this is gonna pan out or i'm
gonna move on to the next
i would i was really good at keeping a
crush
like going like i i would say it was a
balance like
there were definitely people that i was
like oh i have a crush on that person
and then we would make out or whatever
like kiss at a sweet 16 or you know hang
go to a party together and end up making
out in the bathroom or something there
was lots of that happening
but then there was lots of like oh i
like this older boy and
that's gonna be what it is
yeah see i feel like i was always
looking for like the most
viable crush that could actually come to
fruition
so i didn't like hold on when i was a
younger
girl and like i was into romance and
none of the boys around me were because
i was a fourth grader that was when i
would have like
deep unrequited crushes on boys
like pining for them but as soon as like
the boys caught up i was like
you're either we're either doing this or
we're not and that's probably the better
way to approach it
because then you you cut down on a lot
of wasted time
i was trying to find my seth cohen
speaking of people who are still hot
let's look at these pictures of mary
beth
[Laughter]
right subway i you know what i've been
working on my segways
so this seems like a student athlete
photo what are we looking at here we're
looking at the pep rally
where we were wearing our i think they
were a boat house
you know you would get the boat house
like custom um
like swishy pants and jacket yeah for
your
for your little sport by the way i never
did that because i never had a sport
but um i underst i remember the days
when
everyone of a certain sport would come
in in their jacket and swishy pants
what was insane is that i want to say
they would make us buy a new one every
year
maybe i'm wrong though but they were so
expensive and like i don't
have it anymore like i got rid of it but
it was we wore those on the days we had
swim meets and this was the
pep rally so obviously everyone in a
fall sport was coming dressed
to the nines with school spirit and
here you see me i'm taking off my swishy
pants in favor of spandex and then i
want to say we probably had
t-shirts on underneath that where the
the collar was cut
off so it was like an off-the-shoulder
80s vibe
oh love that and that was like a home
cut off
like you guys oh yeah this is very diy
i i loved to just [ __ ] up a shirt
when i was in house yeah you give me a
pair of scissors and a shirt forget it
yeah
you could i i was truly you could give
me any piece of cloth and i could turn
it into a [ __ ] shirt
like it was no questions asked
give me two minutes with this shirt and
it'll be not appropriate to wear to
anything
exactly like i will not be able to wear
it anymore i would cut up the sides and
do the tie along the sides yeah yeah
definitely
cut it into a tank top there were so
many options and i was like
i was a swimmer but i would like go to
the bathroom for a really long time and
like actually just be taking a hot
shower
i just and then what was such torture is
that the boys swim team
would start practicing after us and so
you'd see them in their bathing suits
and
perv out a little bit and then you know
have to go
have to go in and and take a take a
little shower
did teen mary beth allow herself
to fully perv out or were you like
i'm a confirmed cat like i can't be
doing that
you know you think i wasn't imagining
what was under their bathing suits i was
just admiring what i was able to see
the chest the abs the legs that which we
often see on jesus christ himself he's
exactly the same thinking you know if
god if if god
comma jesus can do can do that can wear
that outfit then i don't feel so bad
that's true that's true honestly yeah a
swim team outfit is basically
jesus's final look basically what he
wore yeah on his kind of like
his his laughs his big dad yeah yeah
and what was so weird is that like on
the swim team you're obsessed with that
song my neck my back
and like i would sing that and just not
care like
just be like yeah this is a fine song it
was kind of crazy what would like play
at dances fully uncensored well
i think that now they play censored
music they should i mean
yeah to the windows to the walls like
that was huge when i was in high school
middle school and high school and they
were playing oh yeah absolutely as like
a 12 year old just being like let the
sweat drop down
exactly all these [ __ ] crawl and like
yes
just screaming it absolutely and
grinding did you grind at your dances
oh yeah that's where i learned to grind
was that was that my first homecoming
i remember being scared that i wasn't
gonna be good at
it of course of course why would you not
be
it's a skill you need to have in the
world to survive obviously
i remember being very scared that i
wasn't going to be good at
grinding and then um it's actually
it's actually just rubbing your genitals
on another person yes
so it's not there isn't really a huge
amount of skill involved
there's not i mean if you have no rhythm
it can be tough but yeah
i think a lot of people are able to work
through that in their teen years and
once again
flourish as adults at 100
i always think about how crazy it must
be
to be an adult who was watching those
dances like the chaperones i'm like
what are like
no one was stepping in i didn't see
anybody stepping you do because you
can't if everyone's doing it what are
they gonna do
pull people apart that's true you can't
that's true
no you can't because they're actually
like fully in each other at this point
so you're not gonna extricate them
as long as they're not having sex on on
the dance floor it's like okay we'll
we'll let it slide we'll turn a blind
eye
i also remember we would gather in like
a giant sweaty circle too so it was
probably hard to even actually see what
anyone
was doing in there it was dark you know
the lights are down
smoke machine ugh it's sweaty and
yeah it was a really sexual environment
truly like yeah and it was like hormones
raging it's i don't know why they have
school dances it's like you're asking
for trouble
it really does it went from being like
this very i don't know maybe they were
just as horny back in the 50s or
whatever and we just don't
know they were just doing that [ __ ] like
yeah because the bar to become that
horny
was lower i think at that time like you
could see an ankle and you would be like
that's morning
you need a fan exactly exactly you're
fainting
so maybe they were exactly this they've
been the same level of horny all the
time it's just the threshold to get
teenagers to be that horny has raised
i'm going to write an essay exhibiting
it exhibiting it in different ways
exactly 100 all right let's take a look
at this next
photo we have here it's you and tim gunn
i gotta know the story i'm done at new
york fashion week so
my oldest brother worked for a uh
like a i don't even know how basically
it was a brand
it was like a gown he would make this
designer would like make gowns
okay and my brother would like sell them
to it was like a company of three people
and he would
be he was the like salesperson for or
like
something for department stores i think
um so one
year at fashion when it was fashion week
he was like we have the show tonight
if you want to come in you can wear a
dress and go to fashion week and i was
like
oh my god this is the best day of my
life that's ugh
so we went to the showroom i picked out
this gorgeous baby pink number
sequin there's like a little sheer
overlay it's a short dress i wear with
high heels
empire ways empire ways obviously
so we get to fashion week we get to the
fashion show
and who is there but tim gunn himself
and i'm like well i'll be damned if i
don't get a picture with tim gunn so i
just straight up went up to him my mom
with my digital camera
took a picture and i think this was my
profile picture on facebook for a while
but i can't be sure
i mean it is a perfect profile picture
also someone is photo bombing you in the
back do you know that person
okay great i was like i was like is that
just a random one
yeah that's my brother's wife then
girlfriend
and okay so was team mary beth like
was there a part of you that went to
this and was like
i'm gonna be discovered as a model at
this event because i think team elise
would have thought that it wasn't
it was never off the table i thought
that anywhere i went like anywhere i
went
the mall because actually one time i was
in the mall with my cousin and she got
scouted
i don't think she ever called them but
and you were next to her and you were
not scouted
yeah which i was like okay um
[Music]
right here
well you are an icon of the roast of
your teenage self live
show because of your teen modeling
photos
um which we keep in the vault for the
live show if you guys want to see
if you guys want to see mary beth's
teenage modeling photos
you need to wait until live shows are a
thing again and then
you're just gonna have to wait and you
can wait and be patient because it is
worth the wait i promise
that was from a phase of my life where i
was like actively trying to do
acting without having to do it through
my drama program at school
oh by the way i took drama 101 in high
school and i remember the teacher was
like a female chris farley she was
absolutely insane
very fun but i never took 10102 or 201
or whatever it was because
um also one of my big crushes was in my
drama class
he switched schools in the middle of
first semester which is so sad
devastating
um but that was you know i it was like i
was dipping my toe in but i was just
like
i was so sensible when i was in high
school i was like this is not a
realistic career path so
i'm just gonna be an english teacher
whatever
i think i was similar in high school
even though i was pursuing drama because
um little known part of my origin story
is that i did grow up in la and i lived
there until i was 12 and then moving out
wow wow wow wow that's where to my i
know that's where i went to my weird
christian elementary school and i took
weird
child acting classes and child comedy
classes
there very warped very disturbing mind
um so
but then i moved to virginia and
literally i was i was like
well i i'm already done like i literally
had a child actors mentality where i was
like well i'm already done i can't
persuad
that ship has sailed i'll be a hobbyist
here in virginia
but obviously i can't pursue
theater any longer you can't pursue
theater from virginia
no i'm like i'm already out of the game
i'm already out of the game i'm not
i'm not in hollywood anymore i'm hanging
up hanging it up
so i had that same level of like
practicality
too teens just really can be like that
sometimes
and then as an adult i thought wait a
minute what am i doing
yeah yeah but i feel like that's a thing
where like your
high school kind of tells you that
because they're like you have to go to
college right now and you have to take
all these tests and you have to decide
what you want to be when you grow up and
if you don't get into the right college
right now then you actually can't even
be that thing
i know so i went to boston college with
my head held high
in the school of development the i would
be an english teacher and then
thankfully i dropped out after two years
which i think
i was technically still a teenager when
i dropped out of school but
i think that's when i really decided
like okay i'm just gonna kind of like do
my own thing
so were you when you at that point
were you pursuing comedy yet or were you
just like i know that
college is not for me and i'm not going
to be an english teacher
yeah i pretty much knew boston wasn't
for me i knew bc wasn't for me i knew
being an english teacher wasn't for me
so
i moved to new york and i started
working at a startup and then
i didn't do comedy in new york until i
had lived there already for four years
okay so was was it an immediate feeling
when you got to college like oh
no this ain't it i think i had built it
up so much of my mind seeing my five
siblings go to college and like
like it to varying degrees because even
if they didn't like it they weren't
talking to me about it so like yeah
my sister took a gap year but then ended
up finishing
in one extra like she finished college
in three years
um so i was like okay well maybe she
just well i'm
also i'm sitting on a yoga ball so for
people who are wondering why i'm so
fidgety it's because like i'm sitting on
a ball
and always working your core always
constantly doing work
for my yeah for my core especially um
so i just thought college was going to
be like this amazing experience that was
going to be the best time of my life and
i ended up just feeling like my college
was really similar to my elementary
school where it just wasn't like
it just wasn't showing me anything new
and also it was so easy to get good
grades without doing any
reading and i was an english major like
it's actually
a lot easier to get good grades in
college than in high school
yeah i feel like because you're p you
pick what classes you want to take you
pick the ones that are
no and you know what i just got so
bothered by the idea that things were
being graded subjectively by one teacher
and like like you know what i mean like
if you're taking english your essay is
graded off of like
that person's opinion yeah and that just
really did not sit
right with me even though you know i
would get good grades i was just like
what am i doing this is costing so much
money and i just like
i'm not happy i was just deeply deeply
unhappy i think that's what it came down
to
yeah and were your was that a hard sell
for your parents when you were like i'm
leaving or were they just like
don't worry about it well i presented it
and this is originally what i thought i
was going to do was just taking a
semester off
um and then i applied to parsons and i
thought i was going to do
the fashion marketing program there um
but then i
didn't like that i took one online class
or two maybe and i was like this
sucks and so then when i was working i
just kind of kept moving up slowly and
then i felt like well i don't really
need to go to school and then obviously
when i decided i wanted to be a comedian
there was there was already no way i was
going to finish college but then
it was like okay well now there's
definitely no way well you were like i
need to
save my money for improv school i have i
have tuition to pay babe and it's to the
upright citizens brigade okay
okay at 400 well actually it's
it became way more anyway let's look at
this final
photo of you because we've heard a lot
about your crew
and so i think we're finally gonna get
another just really good look at the
girlies here they're girlies so this was
the night we took a stretch limo to the
spice girls reunion tour
so you know we would work we would
babysit we would we had summer jobs that
was the vibe
and we would spend our money on
experiences and
we dressed as the spice girls we went to
the concert had the time of our goddamn
lives
and you know it was one of those kind of
like
it was we weren't adults yet but it felt
like very a very adult
evening like we were we took care of our
own like our own accommodations we went
to the limo
we went we showed up at the concert and
it was just like
we were adults but we were also really
indulging our childhood selves
so it felt very fun so you guys are all
it seems like most of you are dressed as
spice
girls here looks like you're posh
then we have ginger we have baby we have
sporty
and then i don't think we did
have anyone dressed as scary because of
a pro i don't think we said
appropriation at the time but we were
just like
we don't have we don't we don't you just
felt like you know
yeah exactly we're still casting we're
still casting it's open
but we just felt like not not for us to
say
yeah um were you always a posh girl
because i was always apart from
the jump i was i dressed as posh for
halloween when i was probably
six and i
always identified with her and i've
actually recently been thinking about it
and
i really feel like her personality
impacted me a lot as a kid
i was literally about to say i feel like
you are the posh of comedy thank you so
much
that is truly all i ever wanted to be um
and and then here you know make your
dreams come true
because you know what i would actually
say that victoria is one of the funniest
ones in the movie
she is [ __ ] funny deadpan also
and she's so deadpan and she's so moody
and like she just is like why am i what
are we doing right now
i always remember her line where she's
like should i wear the little gucci
dress
oh the little gucci dress of course
no and then she'd be like um
god i could quote spice world for i mean
i think
i can't open that box because i'll just
talk about all my favorite parts for
example when
the aliens came to earth um and they
grabbed scary's boob
i always was that really stuck with me
because of his with the way his weird
hand looks on her like gorgeous boob
yeah or when they're in the hospital
with that kid and she's like
i'm victoria malcolm
they're like and then and wait
and then he's she's like take your top
off jerry and then he opens his eyes
um it's a lot of iconic it's a great
it's a great movie
alan [ __ ] great in that movie
fantastic
when they do the bus draw and it's
obviously a
and then they get a ticket for flying a
bus without a license yeah i picked up
on the nuances
also meatloaf is their tour bus driver
that i didn't remember i always liked
the part where they break the fourth
wall and they talked about
um that they talked to the audience and
they say things like
you look so cute you're wearing that
little dress they like talk to the
audience in the movie at the end
yeah yeah yeah well yes of course and
and you know what was such what i felt
robbed by is there's a scene
from the movie from the trailer where
they're in the bathroom
and they're looking at their outfits and
posh lifts her skirt up like four
inches oh right she's
and that's actually she's wearing that
classic dress that
it's like um like purple with yeah with
the lace that one of her barbies wore
as well that's what i was gonna say
because her barbie wore that outfit
and that's i had all the barbies
obviously
and where was that scene from the movie
it was on the cutting room floor is
where it was
wild when they include something in the
trailer that doesn't end up in the movie
and it's sad iconic fans sad for the
fans
okay let's round this all
out now i feel like we've got a
beautiful picture of teen mary beth
so this is i like to end every episode
by asking
if you could speak to teen mary beth
today she materialized before you
she has on her empire waist
outfit it's six o'clock in the morning
she's fully done
she's ready to go she's ready to go
she's been up
for an hour um what do you say to her
i would say you know i honestly it was
so crazy i really wouldn't change a
thing
like i think maybe what i would say is
like don't get
don't get so stressed out about like
dating when you're
yeah when you're in your early 20s
because things
will will get worse before they get
better but they do get better
that's what i would say that's beautiful
i love
it uh guys thank mary beth digitally for
coming on the show
where would you where can people find
you online mary beth
they can find me at marybeth brown on
all social platforms
that's beautiful and for everybody
listening at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
south podcast
you